well connect to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Christopher Nolan's pin it is
looking like one of the most exciting
films of summer 2020 with a real twisty
trailer that came out a few weeks back
just as I began my youtube hibernation
because all Star Wars that no play makes
America sleepy boy but at mine pennant
trailer is still there just beggin to be
explained so I'm gonna pull a Nolan in
Reverse time back to mid-december to
break it down for you a shot by shot for
all the fascinating visual clues that
could help us unravel this insane plot
warning against any my analysis predicts
the movie to good and let's get started
we all believe we've run into the
burning building but until we feel that
heat we can never know okay the opening
shot of this trailer is a cut from black
to an aerial shot pushing in on a
building and it matches exactly Nolan's
shot then open the Dark Knight but
instead of downtown Chicago this is
Mumbai if you're loving the music the
composer for this film is live the
Curenton he is on fire right now you
want an Oscar for black panther and he
composed the music for the mandalorian
on Disney plus a voiceover says we all
believe we'd run into the burning
building but until we feel the heat we
can never know this is kind of a clue
explaining the conceit of this film in
which specialized operatives appear to
use a kind of localized time
manipulation to reverse the flow of time
from their own perspectives so that
while time moves forward for them
normally everything else moves in
Reverse and vice-versa
so that way they can kind of rewind time
back to the start of a loop in evade
coming danger like a fireman getting a
second chance to run back into a burning
building knowing where the dangers are
Christopher Nolan as a filmmaker has
always been obsessed with time as a
concept and memento he intercut the
narrative with a timeline that flowed in
Reverse to convey his protagonists
memory disorder inception played with
time dilation and dreams interstellar
times relationship with gravity Dunkirk
one battle told at three speeds based on
land sea and air the prestige used
chronological trickery to conceal a
sleight of hand
even the Dark Knight trilogy films
featured ticking clocks
unfold in precise real-time so with
Tennant nolan appears to be combining in
many of these to generate a new story
based in localized time manipulation so
that single actors within a physical
space have the ability to reverse time
within a loop and use that to tinker
with causality I know I'm using loud
words and none if it really makes sense
but I feel like it's a visual language
that will make sense when we see it
on-screen
the unusual physics of John David
Washington and Robert Pattinson ascent
of the building might be this kind of
time reversal in play like Politis in
Reverse notice how it's kind of like
they're reversing them repelling from
the tower nolan showed how time and
gravity were linked and interstellar so
maybe by manipulating the time of things
you can also manipulate the gravity of
things I know it's a lot to process and
I'm not certain about any of this I'm
just doing my best to make sense of this
bonkers footage hopefully it'll make
more sense as we move on with this
trailer but don't get your hopes up
you do you chose to tie instead of
giving up your colleagues
okay so we get another Nolan trademark
here with the setting of a train yard
once it's on a track similar to the
suicide train moment of Inception that
Cobb and mal used to wake themselves up
to reality there is such a thing now it
could be wrong but the train to the left
of Washington could actually be moving
in Reverse like that first car is not
the engine but you know trains and train
yards will often reverse down tracks
like this to link up with other cars
I don't know train imagery could be
another way Nolan conveys time
manipulation in this movie like you can
move forward or backward on the track
but you're always on the track the voice
says you chose to die instead of giving
up your colleagues and Washington
confusedly coughs a death rattle as a
man now holds what looks like a spy
poisoned suicide pill so perhaps
Washington was a spy or a soldier who to
avoid capture swallowed poison but that
was all a test so this organization of
time manipulators reversed his suicide
so now the pill is out of his mouth back
in the guy's hand and then recruited
this soldier for his bravery and his
loyalty if you think about it this would
also give that organization and
insurance policy because if the agent
were to go rogue or betray them they
could just fast forward back to that
suicide moment and let them die so their
life is always in their hands let's move
on that test you passed
not everybody does welcome to the
afterlife
okay here we see them heading out on a
boat across the water passing these wind
turbines Oh saw the blades rotate
clockwise keep that in mind but then we
see Washington waking up in a hospital
bed and the voice is coming from actor
Martin Donovan longtime character actor
he appeared an ant-man a few years back
and there's a clock behind him time he
says welcome to the afterlife that's
probably him joking around because
Washington's probably like hey I thought
I'd try to kill myself there but this
could also be the way the organization
describes their existence after that
suicide test like their detachment from
time makes them kind of ghost-like
moving on with the trailer to do what I
do I need some idea of the threat we
face as I understand it
we're trying to prevent World War 3
okay this section Washington meets with
what looks like a technician for this
organization played by French actress
Callaspo se you might know where's Fleur
Delacour from the Harry Potter films
interesting that she has a rotary phone
maybe this is just an antiquated office
maybe it's in earlier time or she's just
like a hipster maybe she's actually
really old and wise and she uses this
time manipulation to forward in Reverse
in the loop over and over to stay young
and beautiful just actually like losing
it up there he asks her about the threat
that they face and she says as I
understand it we are trying to prevent
World War 3 and Layne in the trailer she
clarifies it's not a nuclear holocaust
but something worse and I'm guessing
that the worst fate has to do with this
time manipulation Tech just ask Doc
Brown or the ancient one about the
dangers of meddling with the space-time
continuum and before we move on there's
a shot of this driver in an audio CD in
a boatyard he's wearing a medical gas
mask could be later see Washington
freaking out with a similar mask on
he's also often shown with a briefcase
so perhaps this is the time manipulation
tech it could be like a breathable gas
that displaces the breather from time
it's dispensed from a briefcase similar
to how the dreams sharing technology and
inception was a fluid dispensed from a
portable briefcase let's move on
something was in this clip there's a
brief shot of Elizabeth de Becky on a
boat holding hands with someone else is
close-up of their hands is similar to
the shot Nolan use of cob and mauls
hands an inception in cobs memory
flashes of that train moment may be the
driving force will be a desire to turn
back time to prevent some horrible
tragedy involving his wife then
Washington is held in his red and blue
lit rooms separated by a pane of glass
as this heavy concrete door curves open
this same room shows up at the end of
the trailer with Pattinson and
Washington's maybe there's some
significance to this location it could
be a chamber or a portal connected to
the time in The Daily Show but more on
that as we move on to the rest of the
trailer open the right doors some of the
wrong ones too
okay here we are now halfway through the
trailer and things get real interesting
first there's this uncanny shot of the
Magna Viking supply ship moving through
the same waterway with the Wayne
turbines we saw before but it is now all
in Reverse waves on whole notice the
turbine blades now rotate
counterclockwise yet as this all
reverses Washington can be seen on that
vessel doing pull ups in normal forward
time so whatever Washington's mission is
it appears that it requires him to
follow this boat to its place of origin
maybe connected to that boat yard Audie
SUV that we know is involved in the
street chase and it is here that martin
donovan drops the term at the crux of
this film and the title all i have for
you is a word tenant okay I'm gonna
explain what I think this mean but
before I continue
thanks to bang energy for sponsoring
this video every can of bang is 16
ounces that's right no wimpy 12 ounce
cans here it contains 300 milligrams of
caffeine it's sugar-free and zero
calories yet it tastes great with over
30 different flavors to choose from this
one is peach mango but you really should
pronounce that peach man go where's this
man going anywhere he got him once -
it's like getting kissed on both cheeks
one by a big sexy peach one by a big
sexy mango why are they sexy I don't
know they just don't really it's
sweeping on overwhelmingly sweet just
like a bite of the fresh fruit sweet yep
yep yep look folks there are some
mornings where I was up all night
binging whatever extreme service and I'm
dragging myself across the floor like
the capper in both Wall Street but a can
of bang energy just picks me up so they
can star last through more work check
out bang on Instagram you can get 25%
off your order at bang - energy comma
use a code new rock stars 25 there you
can get a variety 12-pack with a dozen
of their flavors flavors like pina
colada cotton candy rainbow unicorn
flavors so indescribable do they have to
use a fantasy creature thanks again to
bang energy for sponsoring this video
get 25% off at bang energy calm using
the code new rock stars 25 and follow
the inventor of bang on this de gram at
Bang Energy CEO ok back to the trailer
the word tenant appears to be some kind
of code word used by the people who use
this technology the word itself is a
palindrome and the title design makes it
so that
the word can rotate like the wind
turbine blades and read the same forward
and backward the word tenant is actually
one of the most famous palindromes in
history as the center word of the famous
Latin Sator square it's a five word
palindrome grid found in the ruins of
Pompeii and a number of other
excavations it can be ready to top to
bottom bottom the top left to right
right to left all with the same five
word sentence dater AREPO tenant opera
wrote us but no clear consensus among
historians over what it means
some have translated as the farmer named
AREPO works wheels or the sower works
for mastery by turning the wheel one of
history's greatest riddles those are
worth noting that word opera in there
because to the locations in this film
are opera houses the Kiev Opera House
and the Oslo Opera House so perhaps
Tennant refers to some code that the
people in this world have unlocked about
the nature of time how it is something
that like the Seder square can be
perceived and experienced palindromic
clay from multiple angles and multiple
dimensions
perhaps Washington will be the sower of
the SATA Square riddle working for
mastery by turning the wheel of time in
hopes of avoiding the fates of people of
the ancient world of rome and pompeii
annihilation it's also interesting that
these big reversals in the word tenets
come halfway through the trailer one
theory that I really love is that this
movie tenants could itself be a
palindrome in structure reach and a
halfway point and then reversing back to
its origin there's a lot of ways that
could work like reversing through the
settings reversing through the mission
reversing character deaths I'm just
really excited to see what no one
doesn't this this section also
introduces us to Michael kite who
appears in nearly every Nolan film check
and at Kenneth Branagh who might be a
villainous character patented in
Washington leap off the Mumbai building
while on the lower balcony you can see
the Indian actress temple Campania her
character's watching and we'll hear from
her in the next section
I have to start looking at the world in
a new way
[Music]
okay this section opens with this SWAT
officer on the floor this is movement
kind of creepy he appears to be sliding
backward up the hallway toward the gun
as if a reversal of him sliding down the
hallway but sliding that's also kind of
weird physics is this building tilted
but notice he's wearing a gas mask maybe
he's on that same time Ben Ben gasps and
then we arrive at they drew what the
moment of this trailer Street chase
through Estonia on the Linda hall / new
highway Pattinson Washington appear to
dry being pursued by that Adi SUV which
is driving in Reverse but what if what
we're seeing is actually reversed and
Pattinson in Washington are the ones
chasing the SUV they are the ones
reversing like it's weird this whole
sequence is kind of a palindrome you can
play it in Reverse perhaps they're the
ones pursuing a guy a guy who already
tried to use reverse time to escape and
now they are using another layer of
reverse time of their own like notice
that Pattinson appears to be steering as
he looks over his shoulder when
Washington's gaze is locked on a
sideview mirror I think they are moving
backward following him yeah I know this
double switch would be super
disorienting to experience which we see
from Washington in the next clip and try
to understand it
[Music]
feel it
whoa okay we might be getting the
clearer picture of what's going on here
that guy and the SCV is using reverse
time to mess everything up and flip over
a bystander car but by double reversing
time they reset the car back to its
normal state they're fixing things
whatever is going on here it seems to me
that Nolan is trying to top himself from
that mind-bending multi-layered chase
sequence in Inception remember which
Yusef flipped the van on the first
stream layer causing an inverted gravity
on Arthur's Hotel layer below this is
somehow even more confusing and on to
the final clip
okay so we arrived back at that bullet
hole moment that was the focus of the
first teaser the one that was released
only theatrically over the summer that
teaser featured some hiccup - editing
suggesting that we might actually be
seeing several different examinations of
these bullet holes in the glass and then
Washington was actually walking backward
but it was verse make him look like he
was moving forward
similarly here Washington and Pattinson
are in Reverse
seeing the results of a shootout that
they're about to experience the
backstory - and interesting Lee they
don't realize they're in Reverse
initially however the time reversal
mechanics work these men do not have
complete mastery of it or someone else
is influencing it in a way that requires
them to regain control of it maybe
that's their mission this glass barrier
may be a kind of tenant midpoint that
gets revisited and looped indeed notice
here the Pattinson's hair appears messy
from the first angle but then as it cuts
to the other angle it's now neatly
combed most likely these are two
different moments two different scenes
oh I don't know do the complex time
mechanics of tenant confuse you too much
or does it make you more excited to see
this movie when it comes out in July
comment down below with your thoughts
follow me on instagram twitter at Ieva
subscribed into rock stars or breakdowns
of everything you love and including
some super in-depth breakdowns of donald
Nolan's pass work like Inception in the
Dark Knight trilogy also be sure to
check out our awesome new Q&A show the
big question which we apply real-world
logic in physics and science to pop
culture like how many people Hulk would
kill if he ever clapped his hands oh
well baby Yoda hit puberty thank you for
joining me and now I will make this
video a palindrome by reversing back to
its origin
[Music]